If you're a fan of "The Witcher,"
you've already seen the news.
Can the Netflix fantasy series really
survive without Henry Cavill?
Liam Hemsworth will take over the role
of Geralt from Henry Cavill in Season 4,
for reasons that may or may not
have something to do with the
latter's recently revitalized
career as the DCEU's Superman.
Hemsworth certainly has the looks
and chops to portray the stoic,
powerful Geralt of Rivia. However, Cavill
owns the role so thoroughly that many fans
have been reflexively hitting the eject button
after the recast news, which is a pretty clear
portent of doom for a franchise that's
named after its main character's day job.
To use an analogy that befits Cavill,
every live-action version of Superman is
going to be compared to Christopher
Reeve sooner or later.
Likewise, Hemsworth now faces the seemingly
insurmountable task of carrying
his beloved predecessor's silver
wig with adequate gruff and grace.
Recasts like this have been pulled off
before — just ask the James Bond franchise.
"People who want to stay alive play it safe."
"Please stay alive."
The difference here is that if Hemsworth
turns out to be a George Lazenby, it seems
unlikely that the viewers — or Netflix, for that
matter — will give "The Witcher" another chance.
Probably the biggest thing that favors "The
Witcher's" Hemsworth era is the vast wealth
of stories the show has hitherto left untapped.
There are still tons of plotlines that can really
grab the fans' attention. Going by sheer cultural
significance alone, this means the show is almost
honor-bound to soften the blow of recasting
by diving headfirst into "The Wild Hunt."
The show has already revealed that the Wild
Hunt plays a role in things to come. Season 2
prominently features Voleth Meir, who turns out
to be a dark elf affiliated with the Wild Hunt.
The Hunt itself also makes a brief, but suitably
ominous appearance in the season finale. As such,
it should be just a matter of time
before this crew comes calling for Ciri.
Here's a crucial question
about the show's survival,
though. When will the Wild Hunt
start making moves? Introducing
the otherworldly antagonists could easily
keep the show going for a good few seasons,
and given the fact that Cavill is leaving after
the next season, the most effective time for the
Wild Hunt's proper introduction would be in
the Season 3 finale. This would provide an
irresistible cliffhanger that could bring
fans back next season, Cavill or no Cavill.
Henry Cavill originally committed
to "The Witcher" for seven seasons,
and since the Nilfgaardian storyline will
likely swallow a whole bunch of Season 3 hours,
the Wild Hunt could indeed chill out for the
majority of the season, only to make its charge
at the optimal moment for Hemsworth to tag in
for Season 4. However, get the timing wrong,
and there's the risk that a notable portion
of viewers will clock out with Cavill.
Like it or not, it seems that Season 4
will definitely be a watershed moment
for "The Witcher." If the show can manage its
sprawling cast of characters, introduce cool
enough plotlines, and handle the transition from
Cavill to Hemsworth with grace, it has conquered
a challenge that puts Geralt's worst in-universe
enemies to shame, and is effectively as invincible
as long as Netflix's algorithms smile on it. If
not ... well, at least it was fun while it lasted.
"The Witcher" has all the tools to make
the change work. But when the pressure
is mounting and the biggest
star of the show is leaving,
many people might suddenly have suggestions
on how to tinker with the premise, or put
overt focus on certain characters. Perhaps new,
non-canon characters that decidedly shouldn't
be introduced will be introduced anyway. Maybe
there will be a temptation to take unnecessary
liberties with some storylines from the source
material, or needless shortcuts with others.
If "The Witcher" can't resist tinkering with
what works — either to take attention away
from the recasting, or in an honest
attempt to provide fire support for
the new lead — the show just
might be in serious trouble.